hey this is presto Walker Catherine asks
how many fish did you catch Barney says
I caught five Alfred says I caught two
barney then says don't listen to Alfred
you have to multiply any number he
speaks aloud by six to get the real
value Alfred then says don't listen to
Barney you have to subtract two from any
number he speaks aloud to get the real
value Catherine knows Alfred always
speaks aloud a number equal to the real
number divided by some constant and
Barney always speaks aloud a number
equal to the real number plus some fixed
value Catherine after thinking it over
says I know how many fish each of you
actually caught how many fish did Barney
actually catch and how many did Alfred
actually catch I think halav or chai
Ross for creating this problem and
sending me its solution it has a very
unique mechanism out of logic puzzles
that I presented can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so at first the problem seems easy but
if it seems easy to you you might be
falling for the tempting but wrong
answer you might think that alfred every
number he says you have to multiply by
six so if Alfred says he caught two fish
that means he caught two times six which
equals 12 fish similarly from Barney's
number you might think you have to
deduct two from the number he speaks so
if Barney says he caught five fish you
might think he actually caught five
minus two which equals three fish but
this is the incorrect answer the problem
is that Barney adds a constant to every
number spoken aloud so even the claim of
six is not the true value that number
six has also been modified by the number
he adds to spoken numbers
similarly alfred divides by a value
before speaking a number aloud so the
claim of two is also not correct so
before you figure out how many fish each
person caught we have to figure out the
correct feeding values of each person
how do we do that let's suppose that a
is the factor to multiply Alfred spoken
numbers to get the true value
this is Alfred's fibbing factor and
let's say B is the constant to deduct
from Barney's spoken numbers to get the
true value or Barney's fibbing a factor
now Barney says that Alfred's fibbing
factor is six so we write this that
Barney speak 6 equals Alfred's fibbing
factor now we have to adjust the number
six by Barney's fibbing factor so 6
minus B is the real value of Alfred's
fibbing factor an Alfred's filming
factor is equal to a
so we have six minus B as equal to a now
Alfred says that Barney's fibbing factor
is 2 so if Alfred speaks that 2 is equal
to Barney's fibbing factor we have to
modify that number too so we have 2
times a is the real value for Barney's
fitting factor therefore 2 a equals B
which is Barney's fibbing factor so we
now have a system of two equations in
two variables 6 minus B is equal to a
and 2 a equals B we can use the second
equation and substitute it into the
first so we have B equals 2a therefore 6
minus 2a is equal to a which then means
6 is equal to 3a or a is equal to 2
since B is equal to 2a that means B is
equal to 4 so we solved for the fibbing
factor of each person we know that we
have to multiply Alfred spoken numbers
by 2 to get the true value and we have
to deduct 4 from Barneys spoken numbers
to get the true value so when Barney
says he caught five fish that means he
actually caught 5 minus 4 which equals
one fish when Alfred says he caught two
fish he actually caught 2 times 2 which
equals four fish and that's the correct
answer did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
if you like this video you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description you can also support me on
patreon and you can catch me on social
media either at mind your decisions or
at presh tall Walker